перше я сказав що це ваш подарунок з
Мариною із депутатами мені на день
народження разом з правою громадою це
де-факто звіт для тих хто хоче
подивитися куди саме пішли ваші гривні
разом з коштами фонди і подарунками
продемонструвати що вони йдуть на пряму
до збройних сил України до арти яке так
чудово себе проявила до 43-ї бригади яка
має на озброєнні дуже важкі
63 тонні німецькі панцири і ми доставили
ушкодження
ніж американська допомога Ми з Вікою
сьогодні ранком говорили про те що в
рамках Rammstein Ми чекаємо багато
танків бойових броньованих машин
протиповітряної оборони боєприпасів в
тому числі високоточна от Я сподіваюсь
що ми також отримаємо
20 22 ушкодження але ми привезли їх
першим з ліцеєм з усім вже
відремонтовані замінені там все ремні
резино-технічні вироби акумулятори
зроблено технічне обслуговування і
ніякої нестороги в командування бригади
Ми теж не відчуваємо вони впевненості
приймають це до себе і
ми переговорили з боку керівництва
бригада є така ініціатива звернутися до
бізнесових кіл області для того щоб
спробувати зібрати половину коштів на
безпілотний
оперативний детальний апарат Посейдон
так чи ні
потрібен наскільки зараз артилеристом
максимально потрібні тому що це очі - це
розвідка цього кабінет іде ціль так
кожен забезпечить максимально точність
ураження
противника просто цінно відрізняємося
від Русі наша Артек від російських
Харків Тому що наша арта одним снарядом
робить більше ніж дня за 20 снарядів
на увазі які безпілотники і дуже великий
спектр різних всяких безпілотників
відда від самих маленьких до людських
все що в змозі там надала держава або
волонтерський фонди
Ми ще не використовували але ви
його Сказали мені що він краще але
інформація йде чекай хороше Випробування
пройшло
пристрілки хороші і главне головне
головне що Посейдон
він засікає ціль і висить на ціллю 10
хвилин 10-15 хвилин а це для
артилеристів саме головне пристрілка
цілі за 10 хвилин можливість
ціль і уходи